because then
quick draws they don't suit anybody yeah
it's just all about fighting and all
about that decisive uh decisive play
yeah um both players they will for sure
have done their research and
it has quite a decent reputation for
black but if white knows what he's doing
then white has the slightly better
chances because black has some doubled
pawns and look at the central tension
now
we talk about the center all the time we
talk about space gaining space not just
on the board but also
and yeah magnus carson he's trying to
fight for that space with a pawn
sacrifice temporarily um but
if white captures one of those pawns
then there might be a price to pay um if
we bring up the analysis board just to
explain the tension right now um it's
all about the
center this pawn especially look at
black's three pawns just menacingly i
mean they're just bullying this one guy
it's three on one they're trying to tag
team that pawn um but now if white
captures then this would be a big
mistake maybe there's a really funny
arbiter he's just sending him some jokes
just trolling him yeah maybe um so maybe
magnus is laughing at the fact that he's
discussed this position with the pontiac
or someone else
before and he's just laughing
at the fact that okay it's common
knowledge for both of them and um
yeah the probably actually a good friend
of magnus's and a former second
and he was actually the first player i
remember this very well he was the first
player magnus faced i just is in my
memory but not just because of the mouth
slit because i remember that that uh
magnus was just pawned out yeah
completely devastating mouse loop i
remember both players have been playing
very sensible over the last few moves
very calm practical pragmatic play both
sides we did see they did castle to that
alongside the queen side and now both
kings taking another step towards the
corner normally if you castle on the
queen side you do want to take another
step with your king towards safety but
the planning takes a lot longer you need
to be a bit philosophical you need to
understand concepts in there magnus
carlsen retreats his knight but it's
headed for a better square backward
knight move in order to rearrange it to
a better square and there you can see
napolita has been playing very natural i
i've definitely approved this using the
rook that wasn't working in the corner
it is now on an open line and there's
pressure against black's pawn in the
center and you can see magnus is doing
the exact same thing mobilizing all his
pieces that's kind of like a
trademark from magnus magnus loves to
use every single piece on the board he's
not happy if one of them isn't working
it's all about that center right now
yeah and it's all about keeping those
those pawns intact i don't think either
side is necessarily
keen well actually either side i'm
talking about black side
they're definitely not keen on advancing
any of the pawns because if as soon as
one of those central pawns advances well
suddenly the posit the position kind of
clears up and uh squares become
available for pieces that weren't before
and uh you can see that napolita
actually chose one of my plans which is
just to put the pressure on the central
pawns and start trying to provoke them
forward because then they control
everything in front of them if you push
one forward then there's a weakness
that they leave behind
so those pawns you don't want them to be
fixed magnus now pushing
a pawn forward there's two reasons he's
doing that one to over protect his
center just in case for later but also
he look at the black queen suddenly the
line has opened up it's defending the
pawn in the corner that was previously
under attack so multi-purpose move by
magnus carlsen yeah i mean very much
balanced right now and we're seeing the
waiting game begin white just stepping
back with the bishop because there's no
immediate aggressive stuff to do so why
not just keep a bishop nice and safe
that bishop actually protected by
white's knight right now
everything in white's camp pretty much
uh defended
magnus steps forward with his rook
um so yeah it looks like maybe that's
right maybe do you have a chess set um i
do currently in the flat here in norway
but
i haven't played on it minimum wage okay
i'm like
no
this is a passion project
well and then surprisingly i'm the only
one among us with the chess set in my
living room what's happening i think
i've played on your chess set more than
i've played on any chest in the last
year
he won the russian championship yeah
december over the board and therefore
napoli actually he's the only guy
remaining at the top of world chess who
has a positive score against magnus
carson in classical chess over the board
um some small changes so both sides have
actually stacked up their rooks on the
same line if you look at all the rooks
now they're all on that d-line in the
center
blacks rooks defending central pawn
whites rooks trying to put pressure on
that central pawn
so again still maintaining the status
quo still not changing too much but
white just trying to amp up that
pressure meanwhile magnus he had a free
move on the last turn there were no
immediate threats so he decided to push
another pawn yeah if napoleon actually
just sits still forever then magnus just
has a free hand to push forward he will
time the correct moment to start pushing
forward his own pawns so napoli actually
decides okay i don't even know what i'm
doing so i have to just take defensive
measures and this move a very defensive
move actually he would have been leading
outright if he hadn't lost his final
game just before the break happened um
and if he hadn't lost that one i think
he would have been by far the biggest
favorite um and yeah for me personally i
would love to see a clash of the 1990s
kids because i grew up with these guys
and napoli actually he was the top dog
he was the guy to beat until magnus
suddenly took off when he was around 13
14 years old i mean in this type of
situation i really do like it like just
to wait kind of choose when and where to
unlock the door and kind of allow the
action to happen meanwhile white has to
just wait watch the door and uh ivanka i
think you've predicted the future you're
a painting you're doing this just
happened because black is following
your vote
black is following uh
well your idea because in the current
position there's nothing else to do but
wait with the kings everything else is
pretty much perfectly placed and
wow i'm surprised it has this bar zoomed
across that much because it looks like
not too much has changed over the last
move but if we bring up the analysis
board we can see that black has a couple
of plans um it will revolve around this
pawn and by the locking key i mean that
black will decide when to push this pawn
when to initiate the action um white
just has to wait and hope that he's
ready for when that finally uh when this
move is finally played meanwhile black
with his last move moving this king
across there's two possible plans one is
maybe trading off the queens oh uh okay
magnus uh offers that right now if the
queens disappear from the board then you
could imagine black's king rushing
forward
with the queens off the board it will be
safe to do this black's king were
rushing forward and then supporting this
pawn push a bit later on magnus carson
saying queen trade will help me napoleon
actually saying no i can't allow the
queen trade right now um he basically
said whatever david would do he would do
the opposite
um so
yeah i think magnus castle meanwhile
okay he shook his head there yeah so
he's not so happy and actually magnus
carlsen um on the last couple of moves
his queen started on the square it is at
now um he moved his queen across
it didn't work out and then he moved it
back so he's actually just lost two
moves now by repeating um his own moves
repeating the black moves
carson was saying to napolita okay i
want to know whether you're playing for
a win or whether you're playing for a
draw if you repeat the moves then i know
you're begging for a draw so maybe i'll
try something different and
kind of show you who's boss but napoli
actually says no i'm not going for the
repetition he's advancing a pawn forward
instead so okay i mentioned this idea
far far earlier um just trying to
undermine the black center trying to get
the black pawns to commit now the black
pawns have committed forward and there's
consequences to every move white the
black central pawns are now all on light
squares therefore they've left the dark
squares out as weaknesses napoleonicity
immediately advances his rook to a dark
square an outpost where um say white
makes a move maybe start shifting these
rooks across and start eyeing up one and
would you have it
the ground and i realized i've been
playing for 12 hours without eating or
going to the bathroom and i'm like wait
what's happened on a quite a regular
basis
that's insane so basically the body just
shuts down he shuts down the mind takes
over and wow i'm not sure i'm not saying
i play great chess for those 12 hours
normally the results aren't great but um
yeah you somehow you just get so
immersed in the game that
we know they they eat also in between
games but we usually see magnus eating
even during the games here yeah we yes
chess is exhausting i think you use a
lot up a lot of calories yeah we've kind
of mentioned that before haven't we
david yep but you know allegedly you can
burn up to 1 000 calories
that's fantastic the white queen was
actually attacked on the last move from
black's bishop uh magnus carson just
relocating his bishop there but lianna
pogba actually bringing his queen back
into the action coordinating the queen
with the rest of the pieces previously
the queen was maybe just a bit um a bit
strange from white's pieces so now the
white queen and the other pieces they
all kind of keep control over the black
central pawns and that's the most
important thing right now if black can't
get motoring with the central pawns
maybe there's just no plan um black's
struggling right now for pawn breaks
which are the kind of uh
most
kind of important way to break open the
position um we talk about that
no look at that oh um appear on the
screen and um
yeah will that inspire nepomiacci will
it distract him um but meanwhile yeah
white is doing a good job uh jan and
napolita is doing a great job at least
of keeping control over the position
just kind of
frustrating all of magnus's plans right
now with plans and ideas just because
you do have that extra space
and the computer
i think just the fact that it says white
has a small advantage is based on the
fact that white has fewer weaknesses
than black does um there's just um yeah
i mean all of white's army i mean most
of them are on dark squares apart from
that light squad bishop right now
everything's intact everything's um kind
of
coordinated that's why they could be the
lights white's position okay we have a
critical moment though um here david
because yeah okay we just saw some
flurry of moves
and in the pomena actually came up with
a threat which uh magnus immediately
blocked and now you can see the kings is
very safe on the diagonal but
but
napoli actually just pushed a pawn and i
find that that's actually quite a
critical moment because now that white
pawn cannot
retreat yeah and so therefore it can
potentially be weak to try and keep this
game going to keep looking for chances
meanwhile it feels like magnus spending
a long time on the clock now a minute
down on the clock and facing some
threats it feels like he is the one
who's going to have to come up with some
kind of
real resources just to keep the balance
and yeah
i don't know david i i suspect that
there's going to be some
something happening along that
second open line on the left so there's
a lot of tension in the center but i
really do think that if magnus is going
to break through
it will be
with doubled rooks
on the on what we call the b line which
is the second line
um a very clever one just dropping back
making this black king feel a bit
uncomfortable but um as ivanka mentions
if okay the king does step back if
magnus carlsen wants to try and win this
game it's going to have to occur down
this line that is pretty much his only
chance right now to try and create
something
meanwhile in the pony actually he's
going to try and play on the opposite
flank and okay he pushes upon well we
there we have it we have the first move
he has lined up one of those rooks along
the dangerous line well basically
there'll be a series of trades and uh
black will check mate the white king now
finally the action is beginning
magnus he's kind of burnt his bridges
he's gone away from the defense of his
central pawns the black central pawns
there they are vulnerable but magnus
he's hoping he can create some threats
look at that queen and the rooks lining
up against uh together again
um
okay napoli actually wow that is so calm
just ignoring um all the threats along
that bee line that ivanka mentioned uh
ignoring the black queen and rooks on
that same line napoli actually is uh
yeah he's just going for it on the other
flank he's just like ignoring it he's
like whatever i don't believe it my one
rook is a very economic defender it
defends absolutely everything and
instead i'm gonna go for gold on the
right side and he's just pushing those
pawns forward it's very very brave
it takes a lot of guts to play like this
taking pawns with your queen sacrificing
the queen
um you need to be supporting them okay
well uh
things are really really uh heating up
because that was a really unexpected
trade by napomniachi i did not expect
him to allow something like that his
most important pawn to be taken off the
board and we did see magnus raise his
eyebrows he was surprised by that as
well look at this that's actually a
really classy move by magnus dropping
his bishop back
uh kind of protecting his central pawns
and stopping white's fire advanced pawn
from ever
pushing forward so the last few moves
magnus is going to be happy i don't
really see a plan for nip on the
actually um he just needs to somehow
rearrange his pieces and hope that black
can't create threats on that left side
towards the white king wow okay he goes
for a peace sacrifice bishop takes paul
um
magnus is just gonna take that pawn
takes bishop um surely right now and um
even stronger right now maybe black can
oh wow magnus has found an even stronger
move bringing his rook across to attack
white's queen once white's queen queen
retreats the black rook might drop
itself down i think the bar will
re-correct itself okay in a moment yeah
yeah because you've seen napogniachi
also realizing he hadn't seen that move
at all yeah i i hadn't seen that move
napoli actually hadn't seen that movie
then the queen's on a bad square itself
wow okay napoli actually decides to
allow black's rook to infiltrate
yeah and now okay
okay
flurry of moves white did lose his
bishop so black magnus took that white
bishop off the board and now napoleon
actually it's desperation time pushing
his pawn forward that prawn can be just
captured on passant but now black is
just a piece up
with that extra bishop it should be
enough you just have to stop white's
rook kind of bring itself up and
attacking the black queen
but magnus he's very good in these
situations he's normally very accurate
and very calm attacking the white rook
that pawn is snapped off the board and
so he slowed down the pontiac's attack
um
why magnus is looking surprised here i
think maybe magnus thought he saw a
winning move that isn't necessarily
winning um but he's got it wow magnus
that's an incredible move sacrificing
his rook if white's king takes that rook
right now then black's pawn is freed to
start pushing down black will make a new
queen and black will win the game i
think magnus is i mean he's basically
just winning now that incredible rook
sacrifice i don't know why he's shaking
his head um he's just come up with a
genius move magnus carlsen and napoli
actually
i mean there's just nothing to do and
now laughing
but it worked out in his favor so um a
bit of luck for magnus carson and napoli
actually he made his move with two
seconds but you know it's really there's
no help whatsoever because yeah
absolutely
black has got an extra piece and a
checkmating exactly
um he will just push his pawn here and
yeah white's king is not going to
blockade for very long the game will be
over black's going to make a new queen
or give checkmate to pontinachi he's
going to resign
any moment there we go
then i mean okay so magnus wins the game
and pogbachie
makes a blunder i guess
he resigns and magnus shakes his head
he doesn't seem
i mean completely happy about his play
here